Nataly one of the themes of selfless is
shedding one's current life and starting
anew looking back on your career and
you're still so young but your
accomplishments do you ever feel like
you're living someone else's life
you know what no but um it's definitely
fun to put yourself in other people's
shoes you know just to kind of feel them
up ascetic to like what you would do it
what another person would do how another
person would act I do live life and work
separately so that's why I kind of don't
feel like I'm living someone else's life
because I really do live my life to the
fullest and then I have an amazing job
that gets me to like you know tap into
other people's lives do you feel like
you're living your calling yeah I do I
definitely do you know back when I was
younger I thought my calling was to be a
midwife and deliver babies which has
been a passion of mine since I was as
long as I can remember and that's what I
really thought I was gonna do until I
literally just got a job in acting I
never went to school or did anything and
once I started doing this I was like
whoa like this I can't imagine myself
doing anything else so now I'm just
gonna have my own babies and just
continue to be an actress
did you receive signs along the way I
mean I know that's like you know what no
I I do believe in signs and you know
looking back I do kind of believe that I
was put in certain situations and times
where a lot of people aren't like I was
hanging out with people in the industry
huge names when I was like 17 years old
you know I was put in places and and
things have happened in my life that
allowed me to be where I'm at right now
and I find all those to be signs I
definitely that's the only reason why
I'm here is because I follow up those
signs and when opportunity knocked I
opened every single one of those doors
so keeping with the theme of shedding if
you were going to give advice let's say
a little brother or sister who was an
actor and they hadn't broken through
they were kind of struggling and they
asked you how can I shed that struggling
actor life and and have success like you
have just keep working hard he broke her
the struggle never stops I mean I'm in
movies in television and I still you
know huh so and try to get the next job
and try to figure out I never know
what's coming up next and you know
you're on this train and you just on
when it's gonna stop and the hustle
never stops so I feel like it's part of
it it's part of what makes us strong and
makes us that actor do you know today he
makes it all worth it at the end but I
honestly feel like just never give up
whether it's acting or anything in your
life you just don't give up do you ever
mope when things aren't going exactly
the way you want or do you say you know
this is when there's times I've had
times where I've had to like you know
I've got an emotional about losing
something or not something not going
through the way I wanted it to but you
have to keep on like there's there is no
looking back you know there's yeah
there's things that hurt and it kind of
a sad by the same time you do try to
find that somewhere else you just got to
keep moving forward thank you
nice and easy
you